[Applaudissements]
c'est bête elle sait ce que c'est en
fait si cela les oignons c'est bête elle
sait ce que c'est merci non plus empêché
son déroulement et jean claude dusse
vous êtes dehors gérard gérard je vous
rappelle que c'est le louvain express ce
soir gérard vous êtes dans la rue vous
devez arrêter alors demandé à la
personne vous pouvez me emmené elle va
vous répondre ou ça ait voulu répondre
est ce que vous savez d'accord je ne
sais pas si c'est pas un métier c'est
vrai vous avez vous avez regardé à la
plata ou la non plus que la voiture
qu'il va aller j'ai gagné mon genre on
va vous le mettez dans les aurès il a
tant il vrai brassage et j'attends
j'attends la voiture des voitures il a
laissé son corps et les angles de
l'autre côté allez-y mais c'est à gauche
devant leurs enfants c'est pour
l'émission louvain express est ce que
vous pouvez m'emmener c'est très très
important et on vous emmène ou à moi oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand même si j'allais liberté par des
merci gérard savage et albert si elle se
régler la voiture très bien aller on a
quelques abus